oh my god just get out of there get out
of there
how is this thing still flying
i i know it was looking like it was in
tatters oh
i knew it i knew that thing wasn't dead
oh
god nope nope ugh everything is known
for this episode
oh god nightmare fuel welcome back to
new rockstars this
is our reaction to the mandalorian
season 2 episode 2 chapter 10
the passenger not an episode do you want
to watch late at night
if one of your deepest darkest fears is
a spider loose in the room
yes oh gross this is
wookie leeks it's our mandalorian after
show that fat shames baby yoda because
that little tubby's binge eating almost
got everyone killed
i'm eric boss here with me it's tommy
bechdold how are you doing man i'm
hanging in there uh what a disturbing
disturbing episode
[Laughter]
as you can see i've constructed my own
blue dungeon here uh
it's all i want to do is be like you
when i grow up
oh that's that's so sweet and look you
can see some furniture behind it yeah
mine is in a window mine's only a window
into the depths of your soul ah
yes yes indeed yes my my blue dungeon is
uh is a little more transparent uh
it allow it absorbs you and then it also
allows you to have a little bit of
privacy so for some naughty things you
know like you can turn around and do do
like some silhouette dancing and fight
um a reminder to all of you watching we
are gonna be here every friday with
these after shows tomorrow i'm gonna
have a separate in-depth breakdown of
the episode
shot by shot all the hidden visual
details and while it seems like kind of
a side episode maybe not a ton of star
wars easter eggs
there are so many cool like visual
details cinematic homages that they
worked in there
the craft of these uh episodes is uh
amazing so
there's a lot to talk about um oh and
before tommy gets into the recap i am
currently wearing this custom
this is the way shirt exclusive from new
rockstars official merch store these are
limited release and even though we
thought we had ordered enough for the
entire season
it looks like if we stay on this pace
the red and the white unisex versions
will be sold out by monday
and and all the women's sizes look like
they may be sold out before then
so you gotta get on this fast i gotta
hurry up i gotta hurry up i haven't
ordered mine yet i don't know what's
taking me so long i just can't think of
my uh well you're gonna say what what
we're gonna be able to deal with it next
so i won't just
reveal that that's right tommy when do
you buy
this mando shirt for a few bucks more
you can also write in a custom shout out
a hot take a theory a question the word
poop over and over again
um something clean hopefully because
we think younger audiences might be
watching um
it's gonna appear beneath tommy and me
in these wookie leaks episode you can be
part of this episode
look you can see some below i see um
eric you can leave the 904 but you're
always doomful
that's right i will yeah you can't take
the duval out of the
out of the kid um and then tommy you got
a regional one too
josh allen is my father and tommy
bechtold is my mother go bills
yes oh my baby
i'm rocking you my baby yoda
my baby no no no no no no no no
no we'll be seeing more of these at the
bottom uh
throughout this episode and you can be
part of this too
just go to newrockstarsmerch.com and get
this shirt
check out all of our great merch options
we got a great hi i'm eric voss one that
i'm going to try to push at you
because i just love it um tommy what
happened this episode
hope you guys did not watch this before
bed i hope most of you have awoken to
watch this on friday because this
episode is nightmare fuel all the way
uh so on their way out of tatooine mando
and baby yoda nearly die
when bandits snare his speeder bike
mando of course eventually takes them
all out including one with his own jet
pack
it's always amazing to me how good
at how good it like disarming people
and figuring stuff out man it wasn't how
bad he is at getting trapped
like he got the old like tripwire looney
tunes tripwire
like this guy has a death witch he loves
getting into trouble just so he can get
out of it exactly
i think he and that is his thing kelly
motto and her aunt buddy dr mandible
i got a crush i got a crush on dr
mandible uh
connect with mando not to be confused
with amanda bull
they connect mando with someone who
knows where to find more mandalorians
uh who this would be a frog woman who
wants passage
the estuary moon of trask uh
which i always just take as an x-man
reference uh oliver dress
for trash making their sentinels trash
crash
lots of scraps uh yeah to fertilize her
eggs that she carries
in her backpack tank yeah she's gonna go
to the trash to uh
get those eggs fertilized because right
now they just look like a bar
jar of pickled eggs which leads us to
the next point baby yoda just starts
chowing down on them along with
everything else in this episode he
hungry
yeah baby baby doesn't want his
microwave dinner maybe once some really
yeah he wanted some he wanted the good
stuff give me all the eggs you have
yes all the eggs and bacon that you have
oh my god
shout out rod swanson and nick armstrong
who played the uh that's right the
person
chef the diner chef in that uh okay so
uh a nice wrinkle to the um
to the plot is that they cannot go into
hyperspace because that will fry the
eggs so they have to travel
some sublight cool new cool new term to
use i'm going to tell people when i'm uh
taking deliveries for work that i'm
traveling sublight
[Laughter]
and sub high this gets them on the radar
of a couple of new republic x-wings
including dave filoni's pilot from
episode six of last season
yeah he traces the razor crest to that
incident mando flees to a nearby ice
planet where he crash lands
into a cave seemingly eviscerating the
razor crest
it looked like i mean it had that great
like millennium falcon the cables are
hanging down that's how you know the
ship's
in rough shape like like that's such to
me such a 70s
sci-fi thing and like even maybe 60s
star trek
i think it's like the ship has been hit
by lasers cables have dropped from this
year
superman three where it's like uh oh
loose wires yeah things
so of course now that we've crashed
landed the frog woman wanders off and
mando finds her giving her eggs a bath
it looks like a very comfortable hot
spring yeah baby
waddles over the nearby egg patch and
eats one of the insides then
yeah yeah he uh he consumes what looked
like a little bit like a face hugger
uh like a scarily uh alien
alien then hundreds of spider-like
creatures including the a
giant mama spider uh spider-like
swarm the cave and chase them back into
the damaged ship
yeah you know we thought this might be
the krikna
from the from the rebels show but um
looking deeper into this is actually the
original ralph mcquarrie design that the
qriket was based on
yeah he called it the knobby white
spider it was going to be on dagobah
this is in cory's concept art for empire
strikes back so
it's a really cool deep cut going going
way back i love it uh anytime you can
get more of ralph mcquarrie's uh
brain brain nightmares on screen all
right
that's always gonna be a yes from me all
right so the frog woman saves baby yoda
despite baby yoda
uh having her genetic line by just
being a hungry little guy mando torches
most of them back he's
a lot of great uh uses of mando's uh
equipment and weapons in this in this
sequence but before they can take off
the giant mama
pins them down as we saw in the
beginning of this episode and they're
saved by those two x-wing pilots who
commend mando for his past
good deeds with the new republic and
gave him a pass
on his shady crimes this to me felt very
han solo-y very like you know what i
mean like they were they were like
god you've got a rap sheet a mile long
but you just are such a fun guy to be
around
you do you do a lot of good deeds so
we're going to let it slide get out of
here yeah it felt like a not all cops
are bad
yeah exactly
get out of here you rascal mando patches
the cockpit and manages to take off from
the ice planet while baby yoda slurps
one last frog egg because it's a little
jerk
he's insatiable for them
why why they gotta they gotta taste like
crack or something
oh my god i imagine that they're like uh
they're like reese's peanut butter cup
holiday like like the eggs or the trees
or the pumpkins where it's like you buy
you buy a bag of them and you're like
i'm just gonna have one or two and then
like i'll put the rest in the freezer
and enjoy them as a treat
and then like 10 minutes later you're
staring at the bag and going like what
have i done to myself
why you're just i live in the freezer
now right exactly
now i must be freeze now i must become
freeze
but they they like yeah you just like he
he just couldn't get enough of him he
was just like an impulsive
toddler which was hilarious like you
know yeah anyway
tommy a lot of people are saying this is
kind of like a filler episode do you
agree with that do you think this is
filler
no i think this is what this show does
really well it
we they gave us a plot filled
storyline rich episode one
and then they gave us episode two that
is like this is the world we've
established
here's a thing that happens in it with a
with cool looking monsters
funny moments funny like irreverent star
wars
quirky moments uh great special effects
great like kind of character development
with mando and the child like even more
showing it even more like
mando becoming even more of like a
father to this thing like when he's
negotiating for his safety uh
and and also mando's kind of like
treachery where he makes a trade for the
kid's
child's life and then immediately kills
the guy like he's like yeah you can have
my
jet blaster like it's like they they do
a great job of reminding you that like
he is morally very vague you know what i
mean like he yeah
he's like the type of person that seems
like they're always gonna do the right
thing in the end
but will be messy on their way to get
there
absolutely it's interesting that you
bring up this whole fatherhood angle
because i think
uh the theme of parenthood was super
strong this episode
uh and i i'll say it's also a theme
familiar to the episode directors peyton
reed
who directed the two ant-man movies for
the marvel cinematic universe
and if you look into those movies
parenthood is kind of at the heart of
both of those movies too
um neither tommy nor i are parents uh
well we are we just refuse to
acknowledge paternity
yeah yeah tommy jr if you're
if you're watching and i know you are uh
you don't exist to me i'll be right back
from the 7-eleven that's right
i don't even smoke but i go out for
cigarettes once a week
um for the little we know about
parenting uh
and from people in our lives to our
parents being a good parent isn't just
about
loving your kid when they're sweet and
adorable you also got to love and
protect them when they're being
annoying little shits because most of
the time that's what kids are
i think that is why baby yoda was so
damn aggravating this episode yeah about
you tommy this is the first time i have
felt aggressively frustrated with him
yes but i i think that's the point i
think you know
kids get that way they're a burden they
don't know how to protect themselves and
they're important and they're incredibly
impulsive
yeah yeah incredibly impulsive and while
i was watching this episode each moment
of crisis i kept waiting for baby yoda
to kick in with another
mudhorn move where he helps out but no
no
he's just a defenseless child and uh
that is what kids are they're not all
11 from stranger things they are most of
them
useless little jerks who just make your
life really hard
yeah they're they're wiggle they're
wills they're not 11. yeah
uh and i think characterizing baby yoda
this way puts mando
in the most horrific despair we have
ever seen him in
i was amazed at how much worse and worse
and worse things kept getting
on this episode and if you talk to any
parent uh
all three of my sisters are parents uh
they'll tell you that's how a lot of
their days are they just keep falling
deeper and deeper and deeper until by
some random grace of god they're able to
limp away from it
and go home yeah i think they call that
ben ben don't break defense
where it's like yeah absolutely you you
you give up a lot of yards all game but
then at the very end you stop them from
scoring
yeah right um now note that uh mando
isn't the only one going through this
parenting challenge this episode the
frog woman passenger is dealing with the
same crisis she's just losing one baby
after another right just trying to get
them safe passage to a new home
even the freaking mama spider the
antagonist of this episode suffers that
same
horrible day from hell yeah some little
jerk wanders up and eats one of her kids
and then eventually she and pretty much
all of her babies die
it's a horrible day for her yeah um so i
don't know if uh
this is valid criticism that it was a
filler episode i i think
if we're gonna care about their
relationship going forward between mando
and babiota we just need
a really bad day for both of them to
truly test mando as a parent for him to
prove that he really loves this kid
because if you don't love baby yoda at
his goo
goblin you don't deserve him at his tea
sipping oh
and eric cue 50 comments to remind you
that that was broth
i think it was tea as well but boy are
there some broth fanatics on the
internet
there's a lot of a lot of broth bros
if they can't get what they want nobody
should get what they want it's bra
that's it it's broth brought the scrawn
it's a brothel
uh all right before we continue with
some of the questions we have from this
episode we want to thank our friends at
manscape for helping us to make this
episode see
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
men actually shaved their balls with the
same razor as
their face well not anymore thanks to
our sponsor
manscaped the best in men's below the
waist grooving manscape
is here to stop your twins from looking
like chewy down there
don't be the hairiest jedi in the
resistance get the manscape perfect
package 3.0
inside the perfect package you will find
their electric trimmer the lawnmower 3.0
a waterproof and skin safe trimmer well
it reduces the nicks and the snags
yeah one of the most powerful forces in
the galaxy is your lightsaber keep your
lightsaber clean
with their lawnmower 3.0 they've also
got the cropper server and copper
and crop reviver those are the
anti-chafing ball deodorant and ball
toner spray
your balls look as dry as tattooing and
smell as ripe as watto's belly buttons
lord
that's off-screen producer zachary right
there wado's belly button what an
image um the perfect package 3.0 also
includes the anti-chafing
performance boxer briefs the death star
is no match for manscape's incredible
grooming tools
it is time to become a jedi master of
your grooming game with the perfect
package 3.0 your balls will thank you
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code mandalorian at manscape.com that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use the code mandalorian
may the force be with your balls
all right let's start with some big
questions we had this episode we talked
about the thematic reasons why
baby yoda is so annoying and hungry this
episode but
physiologically speaking is something
happening to baby yoda to make him so
hungry
and could eating all those eggs be like
bad for him
in the future yeah i you know
i i thought that one the music
the music was almost implying there was
something mystical about the eggs and my
kids like
yeah it was like very 80s like this is
like there's some connection between him
and the eggs
[Music]
but it also really reminded me that like
yoda the original yoda prime
is a very quirky weird character like
he's a straight-up goofball
when when when luke gets to dagger about
like he's like this was the first time
baby yoda kind of acted
real goofy you know like he has like
goofy reactions but this was his first
like
really quirky behavior shoving the eggs
into his mouth so i
i wondered if it was more of just
establishing like right
this is a relative of like the goofy old
yoda and the swamp that we all know and
love
you know absolutely and uh yeah when we
first met yoda and diego but you're
totally right he was annoying like luke
was just like get the hell out of here
you little creep and he was eating his
stuff
and he's just like and i think that is
uh
true to the spirit of the original you
know francoise
puppeteered yoda not not necessarily the
wise old master that he was revealed to
be but like
yeah just a weird little swamp journey
yeah well it's amazing like
i mean that tone kind of got lost in the
prequels right like younger
younger yoda was much more like i i
like like a solemn wise leader and then
like for whatever reason the solitude of
danger
i mean like like most uh toxic star wars
fans
i prefer the original trilogies uh to
the point where i like
i like my characters a little goofier
yeah absolutely
yeah a bit more tangible tactile yeah uh
and and human i would say but uh you
know i don't think we're looking
at any chest burst or baby odyssey um
that seemed like that might be the
direction it was going to us
but i i think it's more of a general
thing rather than eating these
particular eggs he's just going to eat a
lot of stuff
and i think it's he's about to hit a
rapid period of a growth spurt
i thought we were being led down a trick
and that the frog woman and those frogs
were going to be evil
and that's why baby yoda kept eating
them like it was an old like that's kind
of a star trek thing to have like the
helpless passenger end up being the
mastermind evil person so
yeah it's more of a star trek original
series i think kind of like
oh no one is who they say they are and
like these aliens are always treacherous
but like i
right i i for whatever reason i was like
they're having the most adorable
lovable creature in this entire
franchise eating these eggs like
it has to come around that he's actually
helping like when i was sure when mando
went to sleep
and said like you should just buckle up
the ships on autopilot
that the frog woman was gonna like
reroute the ship and end up being some
sort of like
navigational mastermind and like it was
going to take them in
anyway that was i so that was a
misdirection all right eric let me ask
can we assume that the mandalorians the
frog woman knows include sabine wren
uh yeah i think so if um based off the
trailer footage we
see them on trask which we now know is
trask
that that water planet uh and that seems
to be the same location
where they see uh sasha banks character
which if that's not sabine wren i think
she is gonna be part of that group of
mandalorians that uh
that the frog woman is leading him to um
so i i hope that's where this is going
because otherwise it's just kind of like
all right
are we just gonna do a new planet of the
week a new monster of the week
like right right yeah tommy i want to
ask you what do you make of these new
republic pilots being cast as
antagonists like yes they gave man to a
pass
right um but the fact that like mando
was like
in opposition to them and mando has been
siding with the tuscan raiders it seems
like there's kind of like a flip in
morality here
yeah they're going with this i i think
it's
more just like the they are now in the
position of authority
right like they're now they're now it
they're now tasked
with keeping peace in the galaxy which
is what the empire always claimed
they were doing right like obviously
their things were more nefarious but
they were like with this empire
we will we will keep the galaxy peaceful
so now their job is to
you know try and find anyone who's going
to
you know uh uh upset the egg card or
upset the apple cart
uh so like you know i think like they
probably
thought they were chasing down a
criminal right and in a way they were
so i think that mando is just like han
solo in a way like he's the cool
anti-hero right like he's not he usually
is
he's usually what's the word i'm looking
for
fraternizing with unsavory characters
right like he's usually
his the people that are with him are
usually people that are morally
ambiguous as well so like
we know that the you know the the x-wing
fighters are usually like
absolute good guys with like complete
straightforward true north moral
compasses so
i think that anything in that that's
always going to be in contrast with with
armando
yeah uh and that's one thing that felony
and favreau are doing really well in the
show is
showing the alternate really embracing
the from a certain point of view
uh theme of star wars uh which a lot of
the games have done
uh especially the battlefront you know
the playable narrative
and so i i'm looking forward to seeing
more of that um but what do you think
will bring
mando back to tatooine this season
because we know he's got to be going
back
if yeah or or my question is will he go
back because now it looks like that boba
fett
thing might be its own spin-off series
do you think it's going to be in this
season or do you think it's going to be
i have a i gotta believe that
we that i just and maybe this is just
hope
but i feel like we're not done with boba
fett in this show
i mean he him wearing the mandalorian
armor was the most iconic
mandalorian elements of the franchise
prior to this show
right like yeah basically so i i feel
like
i feel like they've got to cross paths
again i also am just rooting for this
because i want as much amy sedaris
in my life as possible so yeah she's so
weird and bizarre as this character and
as all of the characters that she plays
the fact that they're letting her play
at amy sedaris sketch character
they're just like just do you in a show
of this magnitude and like you know it's
like
not that this is like you know the
sopranos of like you know
method acting or whatever but like just
the fact that this is a star wars show
and she's getting to do what she does
best is truly to me one of the
brightest spots of the series totally
totally agree
um well instead of doing our uh our baby
yoda gift thing we actually decided now
that we're
between episode one and episode two
we're gonna do a new segment tommy came
up with this idea of we're calling it uh
man do's and man don't yes uh or it's
kind of like our little corrections
corner for
predictions we made week to week uh and
whether they paid off
um so our first man do that we can
credit ourselves for
we speculated that there was going to be
one last little thing that keeps
mando on tatooine one last little
challenge and it absolutely was there
was a weird little bandit
uh skirmish that he ran into yep so a
man
don't uh we predicted in a lot of our
trailer breakdowns and videos leading up
to this season that that water planet
could be mon cala or camino or something
like that
it is apparently uh the estuary moon
called
trask uh an orbit of a gas giant a new
new planet
yeah to this show you know me i i can't
help myself around an estuary moon
i just uh it turned into something
different it just brings out the best
um another little man don't we should
probably
um point out is the fact that i had said
in the breakdown that that uh extra in
mos pelgo is sam witwer um by the time
i had recorded the breakdown sam
whitware had said no that was not me
the guy just looks crazy like him and it
makes sense for this show because filoni
works in
pretty much all the voice actors from
rebels and from clone wars
show up here or there in in that
hopefully he'll get a bigger role that's
what
this means because he's such a good
actor great i agree yeah
um any other man do's or man don'ts i i
mean i think we
definitely man do want you to let us
know
uh some mandus and man don'ts that we've
made in the comments
let us know let us know what we got
right let us know what we got wrong
we're always they're gonna do that
anyway yeah we're receptive to feedback
you see
me oh one little thing i want to credit
myself for there was just it's a
dumb inconsequential thing but the shot
of the um
camera panning down on the ship it was
actually panning up at the hole and i
noticed in the trailer that it was
reversed
yeah it didn't mean anything because
it's not like there's something hidden
but i'm able to spot what footage has
been manipulated
you've got an incredible eye dad i have
a real job
i commend you uh all right one last
reminder that you can get this exclusive
new rockstars this is away shirt at our
new merch store along with a ton of
other great options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you do get this shirt you can uh
write in a little thing
uh a shout out that we'll put in this
episode um but that is it for this week
of
wookie leaks tommy it's been great
chatting about this episode with you
always a pleasure eric highlight of my
week follow me at eavos follow tommy
tommy beck told you can subscribe to new
rockstars on youtube subscribe to
wikileaks wherever you get your podcasts
leave us a nice rating review if you
don't mind i will see you tomorrow for
the episode
easter egg breakdown uh again a lot of
cool details i can't wait to dig into
um and we will close out this episode
with our favorite
bibiota moment
[Music]
you